a Zelda game without bosses is like a
vanilla milkshake like yeah there are
those who just like a good classic not
very exciting vanilla milkshake but on
the other hand people like me tend to
prefer chocolate with whipped cream and
caramel syrup drizzled on top the real
sweetness of a Zelda game lies in its
diverse and varied bosses that each
individually give it a unique flavoring
that makes every sip oh so satisfying
but for this video we're going to focus
on one flavor alone and that would be
Ganondorf The Demon King from tears of
the Kingdom if you're looking for all
the other bosses from the latest
breakthrough Zelda game called tears of
the Kingdom some of which have some very
interesting details that you may not
know about look no further than part one
of this video which will be linked in
the description below and maybe in a
card or whatever it's called I I don't
know how these YouTube videos work
anyway without further Ado let's Dive
Right In oh yeah and spoiler alert
obviously as I briefly mentioned at the
end of my last video ganondorf's
appearance and tears of the kingdom is
actually pretty shrouded in mystery more
so than I think a lot of fans were
expecting since this was the Grand
Return of the most iconic Zelda villain
that we waited oh 17 years or so to see
again I'm not criticizing though just
making the statement that because his
appearance here is less fleshed out than
his previous iterations we will be
theorizing and speculating about his
Origins and true motivations but I'm
getting ahead of myself first let's
cover what we do know about the demon
king from dialogue and cutscenes in game
long before the events of the game
transpire the kingdom of Hyrule was
founded by a zonai named raru and a
Hylian named Sonia in its infancy the
kingdom of Hyrule had reached out to its
surrounding kingdoms for the purposes of
declaring peace and establishing
agreements and trades or whatever it is
that kingdoms do with one another this
is how Ganondorf the king of the
neighboring Gerudo tribe is canonically
introduced to the Hylian king and queen
as after several attempts to reach out
to the Gerudo and being met with no
response Ganondorf finally decides to
make an appearance and declare his
intent to submit to the rule of the
Hylian royal family however Ganondorf
was in fact hiding his true intentions
we can see from a previous cut scene
that Ganondorf had recently actually
tried to overthrow the kingdom of Hyrule
by summoning an entire swarm of the
dangerous desert dwelling molduga beasts
which were pretty easily defeated by
rauru's super cool light beam after his
master evil plan blows up in his face
Ganondorf spots rauru Sonia and Zelda's
zonai secret stones from like a mile
away using his own natural eyesight
anyway he then becomes rather obsessed
with the Zona and their secret Stones as
we can see from this dialogue in the
false Allegiance cutscene literally
bringing up the subject of the ancient
zonai out of nowhere and saying it's
unfortunate that there are only two left
in the world raru and his sister minaru
then he just kind of stares at him
menacingly and leaves upon being
dismissed sometime later Ganondorf
attempts to assassinate Sonia an attempt
to steal her zonai secret Stone by
creating a fake Princess Zelda and
asking to see the queen in private
however the incredibly wise Queen and
Princess Duo see right through this
deceit and are able to stop the Garuda
blade from reaching the queen using
Zelda's Newfound recall ability but once
the puppet princess disintegrates Into
Thin Air the queen and real Zelda are
distracted and Ganondorf uses this
opportune moment to eliminate Sonia in a
single strike from behind catching her
secret Stone as she falls lifelessly to
the ground I would also like to point
out that Ganondorf is not holding a
weapon of any kind when this happens
which doesn't really make a difference
but I just wanted to draw attention to
the fact that he literally punched a
person Dead with a single hit yikes
anyway with the secret Zone in hand all
hell breaks loose both in Hyrule and on
ganondorf's face yikes again once the
stone bonds with its new master it
transforms him from his mortal Gerudo
form into that of the immortal Demon
King also giving him the ability to
produce endless amounts of glue which is
a super powerful evil substance powerful
enough to create endless monsters
overpower rauru and even shatter the
legendary Master Sword it also makes him
look really cool before the demon king
is able to kill the other two Royal
Hylian members in front of him Zelda
warps all three away leaving the Demon
King to further enhance his new monster
Army and Lead an all-out assault on the
kingdom of Hyrule and her allies
including his own country of the Gerudo
this prompts Zelda and raru to summon 5
additional Heroes as the sages of Hyrule
and Empower them each with their own
zonai secret stones in an attempt to
defeat the demon king Zelda however
realizes that this all must have already
happened in her original future timeline
since Ganondorf ends up still being
alive in the future she then warns rauru
that this might not go their way and
raru responds by saying that he's just
gonna do it anyway and says that worst
case scenario that Knight named link
will save the world since Zelda had been
hyping him up this entire time which is
actually really cute anyway eventually
they do face The Demon King in a one
versus seven fight which he ends up
winning pretty easily rauru then decides
to sacrifice his own life by absorbing
the dark demon energy from Ganondorf
cleansing it through his body and
expelling it as light which won't kill
the Demon King but will keep him in
stasis for a really really long time and
just before Ganondorf enters his long
but temporary Slumber raru declares
boldly that link the Knight wielding the
blade of Evil's Bane will arrive one day
to kill him once and for all to which
Ganondorf replies a battle will be
legendary the remaining followers of
raru then build the famous Hyrule Castle
Atop The Ceiling chamber in order to
keep the seal on Ganondorf intact in a
nice air-type container but one day in
the future 100 years or so before the
present day a little event call of the
Calamity happened and weakened Hyrule
Castle which led to ganondorf's power
beginning to grow once again in rauru's
body beginning to disintegrate into
light as the Gloom overpowered him
eventually this left his body very
nearly used up by the Time Zelda and
Link stumble upon the Demon King's
corpse in the present day once they
enter the chamber rauru's hand either
knowingly or conveniently falls off of
the body of Ganondorf leading to Zelda
picking up raru's secret Stone and the
resurrection of the Demon King the first
thing he does is attack the pair with an
enormous amount of Gloom which mummifies
Link's entire arm and shatters the
master sword Ganondorf expresses the
fact that he's disappointed with link
since raru hyped him up so much and then
lifts the damaged Hyrule Castle up into
the air popping the cork on his seal
completely and enabling him to spread
his groom and enabling him to spread his
Gloom into the world once again as he
falls deep into a chasm in addition to
his monsters beginning to spread in
greater and stronger numbers across the
land he also releases manifestations of
himself called Phantom ganons to see
speak out link and attempt to
assassinate him with one Phantom Ganon
becoming another puppet Zelda and
traveling around messing things up which
link spends the majority of his
Adventure fixing Ganondorf does have a
neat moment addressing link directly
when the hero faces the puppet Zelda in
battle feeling that link was lucky to
have survived his attack initially due
to raru's hand but then realizing that
link actually is you know kind of a
badass he then attempts to do quadruple
the Gloom damage to link but Link's
friends the new sages with the powers of
the handed down zonai secret stones are
able to brush aside the Gloom like it
was nothing Ganondorf then plays them in
MP4 video of what he's going to do to
the world when his power comes back
fully threatens them then laughs and
leaves and the next time we see
Ganondorf is when he's approached by
Link in their first and final Conflict
long story short Ganondorf for hydrates
threatens link fights a bit gets beaten
transforms into the Demon King threatens
link again fights a bit more and then
gets beaten again at this point
Ganondorf is so unwilling to let link
win that he decides to do the
irreversible to consume his zonai secret
Stone and become a dragon of Limitless
evil demon dragon potential then he gets
beaten again but this time link stabs
the zonai secret Stone destroying it and
Ganondorf and practically setting off a
nuke in the process and thus ends the
life of the newest iteration of
Ganondorf dragmire but now let's try to
explain the beginning of his life the
motivations behind his actions and
hatred of the kingdom of Hyrule that are
lightly touched on in the game if at all
and really quick before we get to that I
just wanted to take a moment and mention
my book it's a Zelda book which I
haven't given the amazing and humbling
opportunity to write a bit of it would
mean the world to me and the author if
you would check it out and maybe even
consider pre-ordering it since there
aren't that many Zelda books out on the
market it'll be coming out later this
year and I'll leave a link to it in the
description below anyway as I've said
multiple times so far there isn't much
to go off of regarding ganondorf's
intentions aside from evil man evil plan
because of this we'll have to look at
the details we are given with a
magnifying glass and deduce what we can
from there and I'd like to point out
that if any of these conclusions are
contrary to what you might believe
personally you are more than welcome to
think differently that's the beauty of
theorizing as a community that being
said though I think that what we're
going to talk about today might not only
explain ganondorf's intentions and
appearance in tears of the Kingdom but
also his other appearances across the
franchise as well as an ancient Garuda
legend that has otherwise remained
unexplained for over 25 years but first
things first one of the loudest hidden
details about ganorf's appearance in
tears of the Kingdom would be the Gerudo
shown behind him and by that I mean
these two masked Garuda women in
particular they make two appearances
once here on a Gerudo Highland Mountain
and once here in the Hyrule Throne Room
both times being the closest Garuda
women to appear right behind Ganondorf
these twin Gerudo women wear sashes that
read kaume and kotake which for veterans
of the franchise should immediately
sound familiar this is not the first
time we've seen twin Gerudo of the same
names linked closely to Ganondorf in
fact in Ocarina of Time which was the
first appearance of all three characters
kome and kotake are powerful Garuda
witches referred to as Gander dwarf's
surrogate mothers they also have the
ability to fuse together and form the
big witch known as twin rova we don't
have any such text to prove a similar
Connection in tears of the Kingdom but
if you'll notice their skin is also
green unlike any of the other Gerudo but
similar to one in particular Ganondorf
their shared odd green skin would imply
a blood connection between them and only
them and is also a pattern shared by
their original Ocarina of Time
appearances this connection makes sense
but it's the time placement of these
cutscenes that makes the theorizing a
bit difficult to place because see if
these cutscenes truly do take place at
the beginning of the kingdom of Hyrule
according to its known existence which
would have taken place sometime before
Ocarina of Time then that would explain
the Gerudo twins's youthful appearance
however the Gerudo twins included all
have pointed ears in the cutscenes which
as the very astute fans know is a
physical feature of the modern grudo not
the original Gerudo from back in Ocarina
of Time which has proven to us
canonically by contrasting the
appearances of the old and new Garuda
women and reading this segment from
creating a champion which states quite
clearly that the ancient Gerudo had
rounded ears the theories given to
explain their modern pointed ears are
debatable but what's not debatable is
the fact that the original Gerudo did
not look like tears of the Kingdom's
kotake and kaume or any of the grudo
shown in the cutscenes for that matter
except for Ganondorf himself who does
have rounded ears but more on that in a
bit this hurts the placement of Tears
the Kingdom's founding of Hyrule being
before Ocarina of Time and instead
implies it is after and thanks to an
interview between famitsu and Zelda
series producer aegianuma and tears of
the Kingdom director hiramaro
fujibayashi that was made public
recently this idea actually seems more
likely now since fujibayashi directly
states that tears of the Kingdom's
account of the founding of Hyrule could
very well be more of a re-founding of
Hyrule stating that it's possible that
it was destroyed once before and this is
actually huge because it means that
tears of the Kingdom's founding of
Hyrule past is probably still more
futuristic than anything we've seen on
the timeline since the kingdom of Hyrule
is still alive and active at the end of
all three branches well except for the
adult timeline within which the kingdom
was in fact destroyed by a flood and new
Hyrule was founded somewhere else
entirely leaving the original Kingdom of
Hyrule open for a refounding which would
make sense given the sea salt we find
all over the place in the era of the
wild since it would have been flooded by
an ocean but hey this isn't a timeline
Theory video hi I'd need a break from
those I brought it up though to make the
point that it's probable given
fujibayashi's insight and the pointed
Gerudo ears in the cutscenes that the
founding of Hyrule shown here actually
takes place after the current timeline
within which Ganondorf and kotake and
kome have all been slain however there
is one case on the existing Zelda
Timeline that showcases an interesting
appearance of twin Rover and that would
be their appearance in the Oracle games
these games do take place in the
downfall timeline which according to
most theories is a timeline that splits
off of Ocarina of Time if that Ganondorf
is able to kill the hero of time at the
end of the game after transforming into
Ganon this would mean though that twin
rova has been killed in the the downfall
timeline this implies that their
presence after being killed in the
Oracle games is actually therefore a
Reincarnation of the witches with their
entire plan being to resurrect their
surrogate son who is now Ganon which
would also mean that calling them an
incarnation of demise's hatred is valid
and therefore gives Credence to their
evil intentions and connections to the
rest of the lore of the franchise so
here's my theory for Tears the Kingdom's
twin rova and Ganondorf what if twin
rova has once again reincarnated or
resurrected as they've been shown to be
able to do in the Oracle games and
furthermore what if Ganondorf as a whole
has always been a creation of twin rova
think about it they're known as his
surrogate mothers but you know biology
and stuff does imply that he must have
had a father and one mother but that
doesn't make sense since he has two
mothers unless he was created instead of
born but that would mean his mothers
would have had to have been extremely
powerful witches to pull off something
like that oh wait that's exactly what
they are and if we think about
ganondorf's existence this way then not
only do multiple ganondorfs Sporting
Green skin across the franchise make
sense but it also makes sense as to why
the female exclusive race of the Garuda
would randomly give birth to one male
king once every hundred years that could
just be the rate at which twin rova can
create suitable male heirs each
programmed from their creation to
attempt to overthrow the kingdom of
Hyrule and since it's the same ritual
creating the same being known as
Ganondorf he would also sport the same
rounded ears if it's true this explains
so many things the ancient grew to
Legend of one male Heir every hundred
years the multiple appearances of a
Ganondorf throughout the franchise and
the appearance of kotake and kaume and
tears of the Kingdom's cutscenes which
is otherwise completely random all it
requires is that one of demise's cursed
incarnations known as twin rova
reincarnates once again after the end of
the current timeline which is very easy
to believe but that's just my theory and
like I said you are free to believe this
way or not it's your prerogative I am as
always very interested in your thoughts
though so please feel free to leave a
comment below detailing what you think
even if it's just to say hi or that you
think I'm weird or something it's okay I
can take it maybe and please consider
leaving a like on this video If you
enjoyed it or at least my efforts into
making it and would like to put a smile
on my face and make sure you're
subscribed to the channel to get
notifications on tons of gaming lore
explained in bite size easy to
understand pieces and it also helps grow
the channel so that would be much
appreciated huge thanks as always to my
Bandit crew who make my day every day
and are the reason this channel is still
alive that's all I've got for this one
so follow me on my socials to keep up to
date and I'll see you next time this is
Bandit signing out peace
[Music]
thank you thank you